Denis starts off this hour in Charlotte
North Carolina
hi Dennis how are you hey Dave hey good
thanks and thanks for taking my call
certainly sir how can I help okay here's
the deal
my wife and I just bought a house and
we're able to put 60% down because we
just sold our other house phenomenal
along with that we picked up a mortgage
so I want to slam the mortgage so I'm
thinking we got it we got a 30-year just
to get on the boards I'm thinking going
to a 15-year real soon mm-hmm and I'm
also also provided I can we can handle
that we think you can provided we can do
that I'm also thinking about taking we
got 14 or 15 in mutual funds and I'm
thinking about taking that out as well
and throwing that on the mortgage as
well really get this thing down how much
do you owe
we go ahead how much do you owe 132 okay
and what is your interest rate 3.6 3.6
85 I just got it
we just got it yeah really interesting
yeah it's a little high
well I thought so I thought so but we
were we wanted to just get this thing
you know done and get in the house and
then start is it a traditional mortgage
it is yeah okay and your household
income sir
oh I'm retired I think we're at about 60
okay you have any money other than the
14,000 no okay you don't know you have
an emergency 30 is coming in okay and
you have an emergency fund of any kind
yeah yeah we've got about 20 set aside
okay all right in a separate account
different than the 14 correct okay cool
yeah I'm with your plan I would throw
the 14 at it which gets just you know
you know down in the 1-1 18 or something
like that we got left then and you can
put that on a 15 year normally the only
reason to refinance is not to go from a
third
to a 15 I wouldn't go to the refinance
cost to do that but in order to save on
interest you would refinance and I think
you could probably save three quarters
of a point I mean I'm seeing quotes I
don't know if you can get on mortgage
this small or not but I'm seeing quotes
well down under under three and so if
you got something like two point eight
seven five or 275 or something like that
along those lines you know that would
might be worth refinancing and then
while you're at it put it on a 15-year
and then of course you just chunk money
at it as fast and as hard as you can
like you're saying and then how do we
make that go away well you make it go
away pretty quick that way you'll
probably be done in five or six years oh
that's now we're talking the same
language yeah okay you just start just
kind of start dividing it you know you
say we're dealing with one hundred and
twenty thousand and you know if we
wanted to do that in ten years that be
ten thousand extra I'm a year I'm you
know and if we wanted to do it in five
years
that means there'd be 20,000 extra a
year that's right yeah so that's why I'm
saying you know five six seven years
something like that you're probably
gonna be done mmm
okay can I make one statement sure one
last statement I know my daughter's
listening to this right now and she'll
squeeze blood out of a rock as far as
her budget goes wanted to want to tell
her that we're gonna mom and dad are
going to take care of her car payment
from here on we're gonna wipe out her
debt
no one that just weren't gonna use this
opportunity to do that she's not
expecting this but I thought I'd want to
do this but okay Dave thanks very much
well that's fun huh that's the first
time anybody's ever announced that on
our show that's very cool
well done sir